nick is with us in new york city hi nick
how are you
hey dave christie thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
uh so i'm feeling a little stuck because
of prices in new york city so
i'm 24 years old i just started working
as a software engineer about
six months ago and um right now i live
in my grandmother's house
um she's graciously like allowed me to
live here
for almost nothing since college which i
you know really appreciate um
but i'm definitely ready to move out so
um
what i want to do is buy a condo with
that 20 down to
avoid pmi but because of prices in new
york i'm not sure if i'll
be able to afford that down payment for
like another three years or
if i run with friends like that would
just push the savings goal like further
down the road so
i need a little advice on what i should
do there
what are you making so
uh it's going to be about 100 growth and
uh
it's like 6k per month after taxes yeah
no no not bad for 24 man well done
got a great career ahead of you you're
obviously
not only a software engineer you're
obviously a good one well done
uh very cool yeah you are in a very very
expensive
uh real estate market at least for now i
don't know that it will remain that way
i think delaying buying in new york city
would be a real good idea right
now because that is one of the markets
that we may see
some price adjustment because of the you
know the collapse of so many businesses
in the area
and the collapse of the economy in the
area and um
so and the number of people leaving the
market so i you know
i personally would not be in a hurry
to buy there um and so i think saving
some money is a good idea
and um you know uh
how did you end up uh where are your
parents how did you end up at your
grandmother's
so my family lives in georgia but my
grandmother has a house in new york and
uh
it was easy for me to get to college you
know if i lived up here so um
you know everything just worked out for
me to stay in new york
but she lives in the same home
uh yeah this is like her summer house
she
uh goes back to the caribbean uh you
know for
half a year so right now she's enjoying
the warmth
down there okay so you have six months a
year that she's not there roughly give
or take
right but um we do like have other
tenants in the house um so like some of
the rooms are being rented and
um it's like i do live with people it's
you know i'm ready to get out of my own
you know at 24 and uh
you know kind of start life for myself
so okay go wrench or something
it's not gonna it's not gonna delay you
that much your career is not you
three years from now you're not gonna be
making a hundred grand anymore
you're gonna be making more don't you
think
yeah definitely yeah considerably more
you should be on a pretty heavy uptick i
don't know christy what are you thinking
well it's whenever people ask questions
about should i do this and
some type of sacrifice it's like it's
not bad that you're living there but you
said yourself you're ready to move out
and you're 24 years old you're a young
man you want independence and i don't
blame you
so to dave's point it's not going to set
you that much back financially whenever
you're ready to buy he wouldn't you
wouldn't buy right now anyway
and then in the meantime for those three
years you have the dignity of your own
place and doing your own thing and
paying a little bit of rent and i think
it's going to be worth it on the journey
to you
to get to be out on your own so there
are some sacrifices that's like yeah
let's make this sacrifice because we're
gonna be able to save some money there's
other ones like
hey this isn't gonna set us back that
much but it's gonna give us the
independence and dignity
along the way and that's worth it and i
think this is one of those things
we need to find you need to find
something fairly inexpensive to rent
we're not trying to spend a whole bunch
of money here because the more you spend
on rent the
less you're going to have for a down
payment so that part of your equation is
actually correct
but is it going to slow you down or keep
you from buying because you came out and
you know got a rental no so i'm going to
look for something inexpensive we're not
trying to make a statement with your
rental property quite
if you do make a statement the statement
is i'm cheap
that's the statement you're going for
yeah it's not the i'm cool
don't make an i'm cool statement with
where you go to live all right
and uh and don't justify it and don't
rationalize it and don't go well it's
clashed american
don't give me all that crap because the
more you spend on rent
the less you're going to have for the
down payment or the longer it's going to
take you to buy and we don't want to do
that but i think it's worth it for you
to
just in your personal development to go
ahead and make that move i agree with
christy
so hey thank you for the call